interesting you said fear walls you off
from the other
musicians and what are you afraid of
you're afraid of making a mistake you
know uh bade Hoven said to play a wrong
note is insignificant to play without
passion is inexcusable yeah do you think
uh the old man had a point yeah
different styles of music invite uh
varying degrees
of
um I would say uncertainty or unsafety
in in the way that people might perceive
it so for instance like the tour that I
was just on like playing Almond Brothers
songs like I am standing on the edge of
the cliff the entire night and if I you
know mess something up mess it up like
what even is a mistake but if I do like
a little clunker or whatever it is it's
like so what I like I wouldn't have
played half the stuff that I'm playing
if I was wasn't constantly standing on
the edge of the cliff like wild and
so I don't care about those few little
things I care about the overall
expression and then there's other gigs
that you know for instance if I got
called for like a pop or country session
or a
show the in those environments they may
want you to play safe like just play the
pot and play it with a great Groove and
time and great Dynamics and don't really
Veer away from the pot and stuff and and
I've done plenty of those gigs too it's
just it's just a different like hat you
put on what do you get from the veering
from the veering off the beaten path you
just love it or is that going to make
the the performance
better like why why why you stand at the
edge of the cliff because at the edge of
the cliff is all
possibilities and on known you don't
know what's coming and I love being
there in the
unknown it otherwise it's just like why
are we doing this am I am I just like a
clown on stage like showing you my
skills or what you know what I've
studied in my bedroom it's like no like
I I want to be like pure expression
happening right now and responding in
real time to everything that's happening
and anytime I'm not doing that it's like
it's a waste of everybody's time have
you ever messed it up real
bad mess what
up I mean you know comedians bomb you're
a big fan of Comedy yeah have you ever
bombed on stage
probably I think I think it's all about
recovery you know and the more times
that you fall off the cliff yeah the
quicker you know how to recover and um
the the varying ways that you can
recover to to the point in which it's
concealed some much that maybe a
listener might not even know that you're
recovering and eventually you learn to
fly if we take that metaphor all the way
off the cliff you know you all right I
remember one time when I was really
young uh well not really young but like
when I was 21
or2 yeah exactly um but when I was first
playing with Jeff Beck and we played at
what I consider the best the coolest
jazz festival it's montre Jazz MH and
like miles played there everyone played
there and they have the best speaker
system ever I was excited for months and
the drummer Vinnie was like practicing
for like eight hours in the bus on the
way there and everyone was like on fire
on stage and I remember playing a note
just one note that I really didn't like
and I let it go in the moment on stage
but as soon as I got off stage age I was
really sad and so I sat like on this
road case everyone was out celebrating I
like sat on this road case with a sad
face like booo and then Claude knobs
like the owner of the you know the whole
festival came out to me he's like d
what's wrong and I'm like I played a bad
note such a child and like he he said
all this wise stuff that you know Miles
Davis has had imparted to him and like
it fully H me up he um he's like is
there anything that would make you feel
better and I was like
caviar the dude came back 10 minutes
later with this huge thing oh wow it was
a joke it was a joke but he actually
brought me cavat but anyway that's the
that's the one time that I remember
being sad about a performance now I'm
just like okay whatever like it's done
was it a physical slip of like the
fingers or was it did you intend to play
that note that I can't
remember I I I can't remember if it was
just a bad choice that I that sounded
like a clanger or why it happened it was
so long ago but I I don't get depressed
about that anymore that'd be funny if
that was like your biggest and only
regret in life is that note and haunted
you in your dreams and then like you
know like I'm on my deathbed and just
everyone's just bringing me caviar
because joke went way too
far